in the blitz
thinking for a long time here magnuson
moved to he's seen this position before
don't worry he brings his queenside
knight out into the game
and okay this bishop move
very trendy topical stuff black's knight
leaping into the center
and this position has been debated a few
times i've seen farouza win some nice
games on the white side here
uh black just pushing a pawn
i'm expecting the white king to castle
there we go it's all about quick
development here for magnus carlsen it's
not an open sicilian where we see big
attacks big tension in the center but uh
some maneuvering instead
and prague seems to know what he's doing
as well with his his quick quick moves
and uh i look at this are they gonna
have a draw that'd be quite funny
repeated the position once
magnus will not go for a draw with white
surely you're quite funny if you didn't
just get get to the second game quickly
and try to win with black and
um
he's thinking he's thinking yeah i don't
i mean a normal move would be to move
the rook here wouldn't it so the
bishop's got another square
to retreat to and uh okay this is also
quite sensible developing the last piece
yeah is magnus smiling i don't know if
we can get a close-up he seemed to be
kind of making some kind of expression
there yeah
but instead yeah that white dark skirt
bishop is going to find a nice diagonal
the reason there was that repetition of
moves is that white wants to break open
the center black said no
white wanted to kind of swap off knights
in a good way black retreated again and
the position repeated but now it's a
more normal type of game black needs to
catch up in development right now
black's only developed two nights
white's developed pretty much his whole
army yeah
and i was guessing that the rook would
move to the center and uh now pragnanda
is trying to get his dark square bishop
onto the optimal diagonal so the big
question here for magnus is he just
going to retreat the bishop so that he
can strike open the center or is he
actually going to initiate some
central movement right now and he goes
for the second option
and
i like this move when i used to play
something similar like this i used to
get such a thrill when this move
appeared on the board yeah it makes a
lot of sense
if black's king is stuck in the center
if black is lagging behind a development
if your pieces are all ready then why
not open things up
in the middle of the board but prague is
happy to give up a pawn white's rook now
can go and gobble up a pawn just two
squares away
i'm not sure how much compensation black
uh black's gonna get back for that but
at least the black kingwood castle
that's been prague's betweenness today
yeah i mean he doesn't like castling
does he
will he do it now
yes
no he won't castle he doesn't know how
to he's still learning that role he's
very good at every other area of the
game but this castling we're always sick
he doesn't he doesn't he doesn't know
how to castle tell you well he's just uh
he's only 17. yeah he's got still got
time to learn
meanwhile this white rook is just going
to get kicked around the board so do you
reckon a castle no no of course no no of
course not i i learned my lesson though
there we go there you go
and some big threats on the board
black's knight is attacking that white
rook that you mentioned that's really
clumsy there
but i was going to say maybe you don't
have to move it this is a really sneaky
retreat from magnus now the dark squared
bishops are just staring off at each
other
if the black knight goes and captures
that white rook white star square bishop
goes and takes its counterpart and that
looks very good for white computer hates
though
maybe now you just castle and just say
okay i'm gonna be upon down but i've got
great pieces he won't castle david i
think there's something better no he's
not i just won't castle any doubt give a
check yeah
this looks great and uh after the rook
moves the bishop is just gonna head back
and
i predict in the next move we are gonna
see castling i'll move 20.
meanwhile shaking his head
quite seriously there frowning now
white is still a pawn up we should
mention but look at those shattered f
pawns look at the white king
the black king's going to be super safe
black has the bishop pair
beautiful compensation and ivanka was
you were right yeah he gets there it
finally does and now it's all about
activating that light squared bishop and
i just have to say
white's uh kingside pawns are just a
complete wreck
yeah a real mess that magnus has to deal
with on that flank maybe he should have
taken the draw earlier on yeah he could
have repeated the position he's got two
bishops as well prague and he needs to
be moving very quickly i mean you look
at the time uh he's up on time and i'm
sure he can combine those two bishops
with his pawns slowly moving forwards on
the king side would be a pretty standard
way to
apply the pressure here but
in these smaller time limits these
quicker time limits it's always horrible
to have the weaker king white's got the
weaker king another problem so
looking good for prague here
so many tempting moves though does the
black queen jump out does black just
improve maybe the rook in the corner
swing it across try to swing it
eventually towards that white king do
you start advancing those black pawns in
the center now that white rook is still
a bit clumsy there we go he does start
advancing
magnus smiling he's not enjoying the
position that's for sure so he must be
smiling about something else
but this white bishop now is attacking a
pawn
maybe black just defends that b7 pawn
and continues
his plan
definitely uh this position is so nice
for pragmander and
he's
heads well slightly behind on the clock
so he has to make some decisions
asked how is he going to defend the porn
with a rook with a queen oh you could
make an argument for both
um you could just be a bit more direct
that's a typical pregnant just kind of
give away a second pawns just start
playing for an attack against the white
king but now he does defend
porn with his rook taking a timeout and
magnus he putting everything on light
squares he just doesn't care about the
dark squares in this game he's given
away his dark squared bishop
but he's just going to try and plant
some white pieces in the center
will we see prague continue advancing
pawns
you can kick away that white bishop from
its square right now you can bring the
black queen out
just so many tempting moves again maybe
that's the one pitfall that prague could
fall into he's already burnt a lot of
time on the clock ever since you
obtained this dominant position i was
wondering whether you could go and play
for mate
and uh pragnanda's done just that he's
put his queen on a very aggressive
square
and
you know if you could follow that up
with
the f paul moving forward the light
squared bishop also making an excursion
and that's why prague just tucks his
king into the corner and magnus under a
lot of pressure yeah magnus is trying to
hustle on the clock he's just playing
quick moves not necessarily amazing
moves but um just getting pieces on
squares he's saying to prague okay you
have to checkmate me i'm a pawn up i've
got an extra minute and a half on the
clock
yeah
predictions now ivanka i need those
perspectives
no
no on this one i don't know it's too
wild it's too crazy um i mean anything
can happen i can see that uh magnus is
also putting some ghosts into the
position because yes that pawn is coming
forward but you know white might have
the threat someday of playing rook takes
pawn and uh magnus
that's an odd move it's uh just tucks
the king into the corner i don't like it
i don't feel that you the position
i think he wants to get his knight back
i think he feels that his knight needs
to go near his king to defend so i
expect his knight to come maybe back
next to his king now because okay and of
course he puts it the other way so yeah
that's the only and and now the dark
square bishop has some uh yeah it looks
very scary for white at this position
very sucks pieces are playing a good
role
this this was magnus's plan when he made
that first queen move a few steps ago it
was clear he wanted to shuffle his king
in the corner and then follow it up
there with the queen uh he wants to
bring the white queen up and challenge
trade-off queens soon but uh maybe
uh that would just be rejected i guess
that offer if white offers a queen trade
now
i don't think magnus is even going to
move his rook that black dart square
bishop is worth more than the white rook
in the center maybe you could offer the
exchange of queens and take the pawn in
the middle if it's refused and depending
where the black queen goes
um but yeah i mean you'd actually love
black to take your work here and okay
he's continuing where he's got a
majority because if black gives up the
bishop for that rook you you you sort
your
pawns out and you take away some
pressure in your king i mean this is so
bad for magnus i'm sure it's so bad now
really
ever since black started pushing those
ports in the center
i don't know it feels like it's getting
better than it uh than it was at least
for the for the world number one and
okay the bishop did take the rook prague
being a bit greedy there
he's sorted out the white pawn structure
as you mentioned simon no more doubled
pawns
but he is upper material at least
and uh things up what do you think about
this capture because i've always kind of
been taught when you have these piece
imbalances look at the rooks if the
rooks are good if they've got open lines
then uh okay the rooks are going to
overwhelm that piece he just wants to be
greedy ivanka
open up and grab this pawn yeah but this
is playing with fire i mean black can
grab a pawn here as well right and he
does grab the pawn okay the white knight
is gonna maybe at some point going to
the center of the board
maybe now
i mean
i'm not sure you can get away with that
to be honest
maybe the white queen at some point can
start counter-attacking against black's
bishop it does look very good for black
you just need to survive if magnus can
get the queens off game on again but
prague is attacking right now yeah i
mean he has to defend that knight if he
moves it the queen can step one square
back and start attacking some pieces oh
this is
this is so on the edge for magnus uh
rubbing his eyes as well
gesturing there he's got two and a half
minutes but
two and a half minutes aren't useful if
you're just losing on the board
whatever happens magnus carlson will win
the tournament and get this very cool
nft trophy that you see now on the
bottom of the screen and there is an
exclusive
fan edition available also of this nft
trophy that will be up for grabs in an
auction for the next 72 hours on
chesschamps.io so make your bid
to grab that uh exclusive trophy with
magnus carlson's face on it but he's
struggling here magnus struggling big
time another pawn has just dropped so
now it is a black rook for the white
knight but also the white king so open
yeah there's gonna be all sorts of
checkmating ideas against it
i don't see an immediate win but uh it's
on the brink now the white queen is on
the wrong side of the board to defend
her king
white will block this check with a
knight okay magnus changes his mind
clicks off the knight there he's going
to hide his king in the corner
i don't know i still think there might
be some twists and turns ahead in this
game prague is under one minute
if the queen's come off white has this
three versus one pawn majority on the
left side
white would love to get the queens off i
mean why it'd be absolutely fine i think
if uh ultimate dream right now yeah the
queens are exchanging well he's he's
brought the
knight back to blockade here and uh what
is the next step for black i mean the
bar thinks prague is completely winning
but it's not clear what what the next
stage of this attack is does he use his
pawn is harry porn his h-pawn no he gets
greedy he grabs a pawn
is good why not i suppose yeah and
prague just under 40 seconds
on the clock um i wasn't sure about
white getting greedy because this does
allow black to give a few checks they're
on the board
and now it's just about
relocating that bishop on the edge
and prague is really being materialistic
here he's putting as much pressure on
those pawns as possible yeah why not now
the black queen is perfectly centralized
white's queen offside
yeah and white's queen is tied down
defending her own pawns
you know it's just so hard to imagine
the white king surviving somehow
agnes is about to lift his rook into the
center there we go
surely you got the rook coming in at
some point as well i mean luckily the
white knight just about covers enough
squares for the time coming the bishop
comes in i mean uh yeah it's
and that bishop might wriggle its way
all the way around
in some cases as well and percentage
here ivanka oh come on it's got to be
big
it's got to be yeah yeah it would be
like
a hundred percent
100 100 i know i know i know i was uh
but it's pretty high yeah it's very good
if the white king survives this uh then
miracles do really exist
exactly
okay magnus his rook is attacked is he
just going to leave his rook on the
square he does love sacrificing material
he hasn't got much material left though
is he that's the issue here i mean he's
literally running out of material he's
already exchanged down and uh
if he leaves the rook there's i mean
it's too much time situation okay
they're both under a minute so well the
problem is is that you know as you
mentioned that bishop will kind of work
its way to the f1 square and how do you
fight that black bishop sorry the black
bishop yeah you know what i do hearing
it is and now the bishop can
work its way around if he just steps to
attack the rook there it goes there we
go andy has already had sacrificed it
but he has to say checkmate was coming
more desperation surely than anything
else here i mean he does have those two
pawns so that gives him a glimmer of
hope with prague being so short of time
and uh magnus said queen exchange bragg
says no and now he's setting up rook
takes bishop
yeah he would love to just give back one
of the two black rooks in order to
simplify the position
yeah two rooks against two minor pieces
sometimes there's a chance if the pawns
are really far up the board but white's
pawns are a bit stuck now
and also magnus below on the clock
yeah great game by prague just so smooth
very nice tactically sharp out of the
opening and never really let the
advantage slip
yeah really energetic i love how he's
kept the queens on at every juncture
and magnus
seven seconds
and his king goes for a walkabout and uh
well
bragg is a man on a mission
yeah he gives back one of the exchanges
as we call it a rook for minor piece and
now it's just a rook for night and black
has an extra pawn the white king devoid
of any real defenders as well if that
white pawn drops it's just game over the
white b pawn
would you guys put as percentages
105 percent i feel here um it's high
it's very high i mean uh
you know you have to do a major blunder
here to to i mean we know that can you
thread and check mate in one go okay
well he's pushed his pawn forward yeah i
mean prank just doesn't blunder either
this is the other thing i mean
you know it doesn't happen with prague
and just gonna find a safe square for
the black king and then it's all about
attacking the white king
okay at least the pawn is alive for
magnus but that pawn is still
not running prague playing it's super
safe oh but now i think the i thought
the g pawn was going to move forward but
now prague is just keeping full control
of the position it would be completely
impractical to push any pawns near the
black king prague is just doing a good
job he's just going to pick off white's
pawn
and play it safe
yeah there we go it's
going to be simple now the black rook is
going to come in and deliver the final
blow soon
yeah just a great technique
and blitz that's all you need to do
just get rid of your opponent's final
hopes
and
and magnus is leaning back he's ready to
resign rook can give a check max pawn
can give a check or you can get the
queens off the board
yeah it's in the final throws this game
another queen check is going to come the
black rook is going to join the action
next move
here it comes
and that must be it yeah white can give
one check or blacking hides and
i think we're going to see magnus resign
now he's got a little where
he's still still fighting still fighting
but now they come
he's gonna resign everything okay prague
takes another win
what a game
it's over bragg takes the first blitz
game he takes the lead in the tie breaks
with a draw or win in the second